i am personally a big fan of british
crime dramas so i especially like these
kind of mystery thriller sort of things
and so i would have watched this anyway
and i think it's it's really cool that
you're doing something like this
when this whole project came your way
what most attracted you to it was it
just that was it the story was it the
character was it all of those things was
it none of those things no no i think
it's all of it i i like you
love this genre of show love the genre
of film i love true crime i love true
crime podcasts i'm the first to like
turn on a serial killer documentary like
i just am naturally drawn to
the darker things in life like the
morbid the gruesome like i just want to
know i want to know more
um
and so i got sent the script and i was
really excited because i love killing
eve i think it's a very smart show i
think that the balance between the humor
these like crazy characters and the
gruesomeness of it all just like
just makes it really unique and so
that's what i loved about ragdoll too is
that there's there's obviously all the
elements that you said of why we like a
show like this um but
i think that the writing and how the
characters used humor to to cope with
everything around them made it really
interesting and
and then there was the whole thing of
i'm dying to do something different i'm
dying to do
something a little left of center like i
creatively actually needed to do
something that excited me and the show
just like
long story short just got me so excited
um
and i love edmonds i think originally
when i read the script i was like oh
she's british cool but
but they wanted
what i thought was so funny is that they
needed
like a
something to drop into this british
crime world and so like she's she's very
american
um she's she's i don't want to say she's
naive but
she's not jaded by her work yet and
she's still like desperate to do the
right thing and desperate to do a good
job and show that she
deserves to be there
and you know she she walks in and baxter
and rose obviously have like a long
history um and she's just determined to
like make her way into this little
triangle you know she kind of third
wheels a lot of the time but
um but i i love that she's not afraid to
talk about
things i think that
um
especially in her line of work people
don't
talk about the heart of the matter they
don't talk about feelings they don't
talk about emotions and edmunds just
sort of leads with her heart all the
time for better for worse
um
so yeah
one of the things that i particularly
love about british crime dramas is that
they they seem
riskier i've watched some where they you
know by the end of the season kill off
who you think is the main character
which an american show feels like would
never do
had you tried to find a show like this
like an american crime drama before
finding this or
was it this particular kind of
sensibility that feels a little bit more
dangerous
yeah i mean
i i hadn't really i had
auditioned for like a couple of other
american similar type shows and you're
absolutely right there does feel like
there's that added layer of
danger because like you said they might
just kill off their main characters
um but this show
i think
yeah definitely teeters on the edge like
so what i loved about it is
from the writing standpoint and
directing and cinematography standpoint
they were really inspired by korean
cinema and you really see that because
it feels like a lot of the moments are
very theatrical and
and crazy you're like there's i
if you've only seen the first episode
there's a couple of moments later in the
season where you're like
they did that they really just went for
that um and i think people love
love to see that i don't think people
like to see
we didn't want to play it safe i guess
and i i really respected that um
there there's some things that are very
uncomfortable to watch in our show which
i love i'm like okay give me more love
this
i i love that your character
has so many tattoos i think tattoos are
so interesting because they usually all
have some sort of story behind them
whether it's a good story or not
yeah what was it like to have all of the
tattoos did you come up with reasons for
each one what do you think they mean to
her and and what do you think they say
about her yeah so i i actually have a
lot of tattoos myself so like some of
them were mine i have they're kind of
they're all small but they're scattered
so i
i get it like you're either a tattoo
person or you're not like i love them
it's true that once you start you're not
gonna stop
um
some of mine have meaning some were
really
dumb
choices but
you know a lot of mine really mean a lot
to me and i think that with edmonds
she is sentimental
things really matter to her i think that
all of her tattoos do mean something
profound to her i think that
tattoos are sort of a story of your life
whether they're good or bad
and that was always written in the
script like that was always a character
choice for her to be completely sleeved
because i think it's it's also like a
generational thing i think that um
people in my age group whereas taboos
used to be a little taboo now everyone's
tattooed especially in la like you don't
see someone my age without a tattoo so i
think that it says a lot about who she
is
um and her generation and
um there is
one tattoo in particular
that
i don't know if you've seen this episode
but that does have a lot of weight and a
lot of meaning to her and it actually
has to do a lot with her arc later on in
the show
um so she doesn't have tattoos just to
have them they actually do are sort of
incorporated into the storyline later on
as well
we also learned pretty quick that
clearly she has a relationship with an
ex-girlfriend that
has made an impact on her because it's
brought up a couple times so what we
learn more about that and why it does
seem to have had such a lasting effect
oh yes you will oh yes you will it
actually
um has a lot to do with
why edmunds ran away from literally ran
away figuratively ran away from
everything um
i think it's why she
chose the
career path she did explains why she's
in the uk
um
and
while we were filming episodes one
through three like i knew that something
had happened in edmond's past
that has really
changed the trajectory of her life and
changed probably at like a
like at the core of who she has changed
who she was because of this experience
with this person but i didn't know the
weight of what it was until we were
shooting the later half of the show
um
it's a lot but yes you will find out you
will find out
how this person plays into into it all
and why edmunds has trust issues and all
of that
what was it like for you like what kind
of a reaction did you have once you did
have those answers about her but also
once you
you know had the answers about this
crime and what was going on like what
was it what were you what without
spoilers what were your reactions to
learning all of those things
yeah i mean it's it's always so fun
to not know what's coming next to sort
of go script by script and get all these
little puzzle pieces
um
i mean it's it's definitely
what freddie did so brilliantly with the
writing is he just takes you down so
many paths and it's why these shows are
so great because you're like oh it's
definitely this person and then you're
like oh [ __ ] no it's definitely this
person
um
and
what's great is that
it's just the suspicion of everyone and
then not only as an audience member but
then you see baxter rosen edmunds like
get really suspicious of each other and
you see their trust just go out the
window and
um
i mean i freddie is so so so brilliant
at what he does and
i don't know how he even i need like a
flow chart for our show
to understand everything but towards the
end i think i think people will be
really satisfied with with
who it is
um
it's a journey yeah
this is a pretty gruesome case that's
playing out over these episodes what was
your reaction to reading it in the
scripts and then how did that compare to
seeing it actually visually brought to
life as you did those scenes how does it
how does it feel when you do stuff like
that
yeah i mean reading it is one thing i
like i said i'm like yes give me more
more gruesome like i eat it up i love i
love it um
seeing it was really disturbing like
seeing the ragdoll for the first time
not gonna lie it
it just looked it looked real you know
and that's obviously the whole point and
i know the people that uh the
group of i don't know
uh their name is the prosthetic company
that made the ragdoll spent many many
many months
making it look the way that it did i
mean the detail of it too like it
actually looked like
people sewn together
so
obviously we're filming a show and i
know this isn't real but there is an
element of like everything we're doing
like has there is a
little bit of reality to it like there
have been some dark people in the world
who have done similar things to people
like this before and um
yeah it was it was a pretty memorable
memorable day of filming when we when we
actually saw the ragdoll like
like we had physical reactions to it
like we were like it was it was intense
but um
i think that's the whole the whole point
though so that's good
yeah i mean this show
with this dark good as gruesome as it is
also does have a sense of humor
do you feel like the humor often comes
out of a need these characters have to
keep things light when their job is so
dark yeah
yeah i mean off
i'm just fascinated that people actually
do that for a living because how do you
live your life how do you go home to
your kids and your your family how do
you
leave your work at home and i think that
the only answer is you have to do it
through humor you have to keep things
light it has to be a coping mechanism
um
at least for the characters in the show
i think that that's just how they deal
with
this day-to-day
case that they're dealing with all the
cases that they deal with um
but what what's so great about the
writing is i don't think that the humor
i feel like it's perfectly like woven
into
um the dialogue and the tone of the show
it doesn't ever feel like we're trying
to
take away from what's happening it just
is very realistic i think like as humans
that's what we do we make light of
things because
otherwise how else do you deal with it
have you had conversations about how
this show could continue is this
something that you know a character that
you're hoping to play for a bit longer
because she's many years so so many more
years of it no you know what i
i think we end it in a way that's really
strong and satisfying but
but of course i mean of course we would
love to to keep going i think that i so
loved working with talisa and henry on a
level that i had not experienced before
i had so much respect for them they
worked really hard i learned
they're all they're both
theatrically trained and i'm not and so
i just felt like i learned so much from
them and
um sally freddie everyone involved it
was like just so special to me so i mean
personally i would love to keep playing
edmonds i would love to live in this
world more
um i think the possibilities are kind of
endless with the show like this so
we shall see
i think it's so interesting the the
parallel between
something like this and doing something
like pretty little liars where you also
did dark material you did this you know
season
these seasons long mysteries and did you
ever think about that and think about
any connections to
how different you are now than you were
when you did that and how there is like
a similar
sort of feeling to the content
yeah there there is um
there definitely are some similarities i
mean i think the girls and pretty little
liars they kind of
took pride in being the town detectives
like the uh the unofficial detectives
because the police force in that town
was crap they didn't do anything
um so i mean obviously pll skews a lot
younger a lot less realistic um but but
both of the shows
live in like a heightened reality
um
but but ragdoll feels
um
i'm obviously way older than when i was
when i did pll but ragdoll feels
like a new chapter in my life just as
far as where i'm at personally where i'm
at in my career
um
but
but yeah there are like certain strings
that sort of make them very similar i
think that the people who watch pll who
have grown up with me
are old enough to appreciate a show like
ragdoll so
hopefully they'll be into it
yeah how different do you feel as an
actor i mean do you feel like you've
just learned so much more since your
time doing that show to where you are
now
i mean i do i think that
being on a show that went as long
i mean we went for almost eight years a
hundred
and a lot of episodes 160 episodes i
mean that was a time in my life where i
really honed my craft and knew like oh i
actually love what i do this is great
and i learned all the technical aspects
of
of like how to hit a mark how to find
your light like all of those things
um and towards the end of that show
obviously i think we were all ready to
like move on and try different things
um and i've been
just really fortunate enough that people
have allowed me to to dip my toes in in
different characters and like with
everyone involved with ragdoll like i
was so grateful that they believed in me
for this role and were like
this is so different for you but we
believe you can do this and like that
meant so much to me because
i know i can do all these things but
like getting people to actually
see you in that light like it was really
important to me and like this is
a turning point in my career i feel like
because i could keep doing like romantic
comedies and things like that all day
long and i really enjoy that and that's
really fun but
as a artist and as an actor like i
actually creatively need to do things
that challenge me or
it's just not fun for me so so i'm at
the point now where i
i'm like willing to take risks i'm
willing to like fail if i need to to
to just get excited i think like as an
actor you
i can't do the same thing over and over
again and
um
and so
yes to answer your question i do feel
like a different
a different actor now because i i i've
learned and i've grown and i'll continue
to do that with experiences like this so
lots of gratitude over here for sure
well thank you for talking about the
show the character she's
awesome i'm i'm definitely excited to
take the rest of her journey this season
great thank you so much it's really good
to see you